we're not aware of any apologies so the
first
item on the agenda is to note the terms
of reference
for this municipal year which were
agreed
at annual council on the 25th
uh next item for noting is committee
membership for 2021
again as agreed at the annual general
meeting of council
the minutes of the meeting on the 8th of
september
are they approved as a correct record
i'll move those
chair thank you are they seconded
i'll second those then right um i'm not
aware that we've received any questions
from the public could you confirm that's
accurate alex seconded can you hear me
yes again no questions have been
received from the public
i have not been notified of any urgent
business
so we will now move on to item seven
which is the public sector
exit cap and pension reform
and i believe sarah you're going to talk
to this item
i'm going to start on this council then
thank you very much and if it's okay
with the committee
can i suggest that we take items seven
and eight together because they are
intrinsically linked
um absolutely yeah by way of an
introduction
to these papers and in 2015 the
government announced plans to introduce
the cap on exit payments in the public
sector
and a period of consultation was held
between april and every july
2019 which resulted in a set of draft
regulations being issued later in july
2019.
the draft regulations have now been
passed in parliament
hacking gangs of payments to public
savings at 95k
with effect from the 4th of november
and however we find ourselves in a state
of books as mhclg
in conjunction with the local government
pensions students seek to consult with a
view
to align and pension pension scheme
rules with the exact legislation
so i'm now going to hand down the vet to
kate stamen and
i think you may have joined us to take
you through the contents of paper seven
and then angela b
there's gonna come in to cover off some
of the content
in eight and uh we'll
take questions at the end of that on the
entirety of
of what we are intending to share so
kate
over to you thank you thank you sarah
um yes so sarah's outlined um we've got
paper on the exit
cap and the pensions reform so there are
two changes that affect the exit package
that
public sector particularly for both
changes local authority employers can
access
they're separate changes but they're
linked so first of all look at the exit
pay cap so sarah's giving you a bit
about the context and the history
this one's taken quite a long time to
get to finals of legislative process
and actually said it came in on the 4th
of november
and basically the exit cap of 95k covers
any settlement payments
and so that includes redundancy payments
um
voluntary severance payments but also
pension string costs are there that bulk
the biggest payments essentially
and as this has come in there has been
concern from many different quarters
regarding the timing
and particularly the fact that the
supporting local government
pension scheme regulation changes hadn't
been put in place before this
legislation came into force
um and the the impact of that
essentially means that some
organizations are in an
intractable position where the cap
legislation means that they can't pay
employees more than 95k
however the local government pension
scheme regulations mean that
the employee has the right to an
unreduced pension
um and then the strain costs that go
with that for the organization
plus redundancy pay which could total
more than 95k so it's a really really
difficult period until this
is you know is resolved um and there is
some legal challenge from some
organizations but obviously the
legislation
is enforced at the moment so we have to
ensure we you know we accommodate and we
live by that
um in terms of our specific position at
the moment with voluntary severance
um it's not causing us as big as a
headache as it might with some
organizations
and that's because our scheme is
voluntary so for organizations that are
going by compulsory redundancy right now
they're in a in a much more tricky
position basically
um but obviously we're making sure that
we get all the changes
um in place um and we will look at our
policies
to ensure that they are realigned based
on the change
so that was the first change the second
is the public sector
exit payments reform um so for this one
it was talked about you know going back
a few years a similar time to the public
sector exit pay cap of 95k
however more recently it's been it's had
a much lower level of publicity and
focus on these proposals
um however the impact is actually much
more wide-ranging than the 95k
cap um and you know said there are
several changes
as part of the reform but the key one is
around access to the pension for
public sector and pension members
um so what happens currently is
employees who are leaving
um the council due to redundancy or
accessing
um or due to business efficiency if
they're over 55
and in the pension scheme um for two
years they get automatic access to one
reduced pension
plus they get the redundancy pay or the
voluntary severance pay so they
basically get both
however the draft regulations mean
essentially this group can no longer
have both
um if they want to take on reduced
pension when they leave
essentially they have to forfeit their
redundancy or severance pay or part of
that
um if their redundancy pay is greater
than the strain cost or the cost
that we pay to the pension fund to
release them earlier
um because they're accessing a greater
pension for a greater number of years
and then they get to keep a bit of that
voluntary severance package or
redundancy package
um so basically what it means is staff
will not be able to have both and they
will have options around their pension
and so there'll be several different
options so the current position is that
comes
consultation on the draft regulations
closes on the 18th of december
and we anticipate that the regulations
may come in in january
however sorry it's adorable however
unfortunately um
unfortunately there's no guarantees of
the time scales it's obviously in the
interest of the pension scheme and the
government for the changes to come in as
quickly as possible because of this
conflict currently
and we just have to wait and see when
that finally comes in
um so during the voluntary severance
process that we've got in place at the
moment
when we become aware of the changes um
we
staff generally went out to everybody
but all those staff who had applied for
the voluntary severance scheme
who were impacted by these changes we
also wrote to them directly to detail
the current position
and what the draft you know regulations
are essentially saying
and we've also also offered that they
can contact um our pensions officer
to have conversations about what it
might mean for them
and their potential package um so say
the timing has been really really
difficult but we've you know
continually been updating ourselves and
making sure that we're communicating
what it means
as the position changes um
so again when the new regulations are
effective we will receive
we will revise all our relevant policies
including the paid policy statement
um to make sure they're all in line with
the changes in the new position
okay and that's it for me on that one
thank you kate
does anybody have any questions for
either kate or sarah on this item
no no please yes please click
go ahead counselor yes could i just ask
um i mean i accept that the timings are
always
blinking difficult under in these
circumstances
um but kate you mentioned that um
decisions going to be made in december
or consultations going on
through december will a paper come back
to this committee
with the final recommendation yeah so so
essentially we have no control over the
the regulations that are put in place by
a local government pension scheme but
once those regulations are enacted
we will come back to employment
committee with a paper to update you as
to what's being agreed
um because that will then you know you
know play out in the
new pension rates and they will be you
know in statute and so yeah we'll come
back with that
could i suggest um that we note
in the paper and await further
final recommendations certainly
thank you councillor rigby does anybody
else have any questions
can nobody see me go ahead aquila
so it's um okay just a quick one and
obviously this is going to have an
impact on on a number of people and i
was wondering how's that
impacting with our voluntary redundancy
has it
have we seen any significant um
numbers of people it might affect who
would have who put themselves forward
and now are considering otherwise
um we have don't need to answer that
sarah she's gonna say angela's going to
cover that now isn't she on the on the
vs
keeler i'm happy if we pick that up with
the vs update would that be okay
yeah fine because yes the short answer
is yes
we have seen an effect but we'll pick it
up in terms of the broader update
on our workforce proposals thank you
do you want to move into that section
then now sarah
thank you i think angela's going to to
pick up this and i'll chip in no doubt
angela are you ready i know you've got
some builders in so i'm happy to carry
on with it
no it's it's absolutely fine i just
thought i'd let you know they've
actually
um stopped now so hopefully they'll uh
let me finish
okay so um in the report we we kind of
talked about this last time in the
employment committee report
um on the 8th of september where we
outlined our plans to
communicate to our employees three
voluntary workforce schemes
so i guess you know just a bit of a an
introduction with the recent phases of
the pandemic
i think we've all recognized that we all
need to work differently
and how by using the technology that's
more widely available to us this has
improved how we can communicate
so we've recognized that we can be much
more agile and we want to continue
maximize that way of working whether
that's working at home when the builders
are not
making noises next door that's been down
points
and and also whether that's in the
office we now know that we can deliver
services very differently
and who knew for example we would be
hosting committee meetings um for
example
as as the norm so again i think we did
talk about the range of options um that
helped us to think differently about how
our approach to work and learning from
you know all the things that we've done
over the first
phase of the pandemic and it's led us to
be able to offer some voluntary
workforce proposals so i'm going to just
update on the three schemes that we put
in place one of which is the
voluntary severance scheme so we
launched the scheme on the 11th of
september
we had an initial closing date of the
5th of october
and the initial intention was to be able
to establish some budget savings from
the scheme
and we wanted to inform a draft budget
report that was being published
in october we recognized that the time
scales initially were really tight
um and that you know that was quite
probably quite ambitious so we listened
to feedback
from our employees and we extended the
the scheme deadlines
and i guess with the impact of the
and the local government exit pay reform
as kate's already outlined the timing of
which
they'd come in really quickly and so we
took a
position and to extend the deadlines of
the scheme
and to allow our employees to take some
advice and for us to
be able to provide them with some more
with some advice
on what the implications of the um the
legislative changes were
i think it's fair to say at this point
as well is that the legislative changes
come in quite quickly and at the same
time you know we had to kind of get up
to speed with the impact
as well at the same time so it was you
know the timing of which wasn't
wasn't really great great for us i'll be
honest with you
thanks for the update then we've had
over 180 applications received from
across our
directorates we're in the process of the
approval stage so heads of service have
assessed
each application and given an initial
recommendation for approval
each departmental management team has
then considered all the applications for
their directorate
a large version of applications are from
services where it's
already really difficult to release for
example in our traded services
and our social work um arenas
so for example there's the date there's
around 43 applications that we
are recommending that will be
recommended potentially for releasing
this first
phase with a further 30 under further
consideration
and these are linked to future service
reviews
the approvals process is taking place
this week and that's with the
corporate director of finance um which
is nikki bishop
and sarah who's our corporate director
for strategy and resources
they've met initially to review all the
recommendations and finalizing decisions
were released this week and they will
then be ratified by the chief executive
so once the final decisions have been
made all those who
who have applied will be advised of the
outcome by their manager
both verbally and obviously followed up
in in writing
and then it's all the preparation to
actually get the release
in place um subject and obviously align
to
the merging um detail of of the
legislation we're working really closely
with our legal colleagues
who ensure that it is um you know robust
and obviously legally compliant and
we'll be looking at the best solution
for those individuals so the second
scheme
um that we talked to you about in
september was the
option for employees to move to a more
flexible working arrangement and the
nine-day fortnight in particular was
was promoted as you know we already
offer a really wide range of flexible
working arrangements and staff can
request those at any time um
one that we were particularly um
promoting was the the nine-day fortnight
where employees reduce the working hours
so that they have an additional
non-working day every two weeks and
again
in light of the year that we've had and
the recognition of
of you know being able to balance kind
of working life and and home life
and we really wanted to to encourage um
that as a as an option so in the
promotion window we had around 20
employees who
indicated that they would like to apply
for this arrangement and those
applications are going through
the um approvals process at this point
in time
and the final scheme is a leave purchase
scheme
which we offer to our employees every
year where
they can request to buy additional leave
between one and ten days
and pro writer obviously for part-time
employees and pay deductions are then
spread
over the 12 months of the leave year and
this is a really great scheme because it
supports employees to achieve a better
work life balance
provides us with a little bit of savings
but more importantly employees can
spread the cost
over the 12 months of the year and enjoy
additional
timeouts as well so the window for
applications is open between november
and the end of january
and we've communicated the scheme and
once the scheme window has closed in
february
we'll have a better idea of the take-up
of the scheme and we'll present a
further report back to
this committee in march on what the
take-up is like
um i think you know we've already said
it i think throughout throughout the
the early meetings i think our workforce
are our
greatest asset they've worked tirelessly
over the last year during the pandemic
to keep essential services running
supporting our residents our businesses
and our service users
and you know through what's really
unprecedented times while
obviously balancing priority business as
usual projects
and addressing some of the budget
constraints as well
but these proposals were put in place to
give employees a place
really in how they want to they might
want to adjust their working patterns
they might want to take additional leave
and or in some cases they might want to
leave the council on volunteer grounds
so again it's it's it's an update um
based on you know kind of where we are
at the moment and a further report will
will come into the march committee
um which is not that long off is it
really and the way the months are kind
of flying at the moment
where we'll we'll we'll update you on
the outcome
of all of those workforce proposals um
and this this particular report is is
the noting at this stage
for any questions or comments
thank you angela does anybody have any
questions for angela
can i just ask certainly that's one yeah
and thanks for the uh report um
i think i think it is helpful uh
obviously
uh i think with all the changes that are
being made it
it makes life more difficult doesn't it
um
but in any case i i
i'm assuming that there was no sort of
kind of figure that was estimated on
what um what was expected in terms of
the voluntary redundancies package
um but
did was there any figure in mind
should i say and are we anywhere near do
you think
reaching that level okay i i will answer
that question
so yes we did forecast we did have a
forecast figure in mind and we based our
estimates on the fact that we thought
that we would
um potentially be able to release up to
100 colleagues
part of our voluntary seven aim program
so as angela said we are around 180
applications that possibly could have
been a touch more
but colleagues decided to withdraw
because or not
with an application based upon this
period of books that we find ourselves
in
and we have the phase review panel
tomorrow
and at the moment we've got 43 yeses
going through
so we are some way off the top of the
financial target
that we um that we had linked to this
so our our plan is to
allow the regulations and the
legislation to work its way
through the system and then to reopen
the scheme again
in january when colleagues may then have
the relevant information to make a
balanced and informed decision
around their future and that will also
include the broader
workforce options again so we'll
reiterate the nine day format
as well thank you very much sarah
any further questions
go ahead counselor yes um yes thanks
very much you need angela for
your report i mean this is obviously
any any changes in the organization is
always outside this committee's remit
but it will we recognize i think
chairman that it will bring greater
workload on our hr staff
to ensure fairness you know we're in
uncharted waters
and anybody who's going to try and
second guess
what the workforce is going to look like
in the next 12 months
is a wiser man than me although that
wouldn't be very difficult
um no need to laugh counselor acton
um i'd just like to say that
what one thing that does and i know it's
at your heart as well chairman
but with the redundancies it always
warns me that it could be an extension
to a demand
for agency workers because the council
does have to
meet its statutory obligations and in
fairness to our
own staff i hope that
hr will ensure that this fairness all
round and bear this in mind
thank you
just do you want to respond to that
sarah
to respond to that because it's a really
good one councillor rigby and
um when we started off reviewing
through the sort of scheme rules around
the process
we did we did wonder whether we would we
should identify the statutory rules that
we just couldn't accept applications
but we wanted to be fair and we wanted
to give all colleagues the opportunity
to apply
under the sea and what what the process
has flushed out is that you are you are
100
right there are roles that we just
cannot release staff from
because of that statutory obligation to
provide the best possible services
so that is the reason why the overtake
of the scheme
and the release in the scheme is quite
loud
thank you very much indeed thank you
thank you
councillor councillor rose do you have a
question
please thank you it's around the pension
uh pension scheme reforms in the report
which i had to reach a few times to get
my head around it
was too cancelled
in the report it mentions a transition
a possible transition period of
um if agreements are made before the
rule comes in or up to six months
afterwards
and when will we know about that and
is that a benefit to our workers would
that help them make
a clearer decision and will it help that
possibly less will lose out
or does it not make any difference can
you explain a bit don't need to answer
that
yeah so basically the draft regulations
but be mindful these are only draft
regulations currently under consultation
the draft regulations do have a
provision for transition period
and that basically means if we have
reached formal agreement with an
employee that they can be released
through voluntary severance
before the regulations are finally
enforced and signed off from you know
come into practice
then as long as the employee leaves
within six months of the regulations
coming into force
they would receive the package under the
existing regulations
however we'd need to have the formal
sort of legal
agreement and so the issue is around the
timing
because obviously the regulations are
draft at the moment so we don't have
certainty as to what they're going to
look like in the future so this is this
is what makes it such a complicated
situation
we don't know what those regulations are
going to be so how can we say to the
employee
this is going to be your package under
the new regulations so it's quite a bind
at the moment
so there are transitional regulations
but say we we don't know for sure until
the regulations come in what they will
look like will they be in there
um yeah that's the difficulty at the
moment but it may benefit them but we're
working with legal
to try and navigate this situation at
the moment to try and
produce the best outcome really thank
you
alex oh sorry i've lost the screen alex
i've got
sound but no vision council then
we've got councillor waiting to come in
because it was 180 who applied in 107
haven't gone through because these
for whatever reasons of those 107 how
many of them withdrew their applications
because of this
cap what percentage roughly
sorry game comes back and over just to
be clear the 180 were confined
applications we lost applications prior
to
prior to 180 so we may have been
say 190 and 10 people dropped out
right since we've had our application
submitted
yes sir um sarah i've got the figures so
i think we lost about 15 applications
linked to the pension regulation reform
yeah
15 right okay it's not as big an issue
as i thought
still significant but yeah okay
thanks apologies i can't see if anybody
else is waiting to come in
councillor thompson's waiting to ask a
question as well
go ahead counselor thompson
oh sorry i've asked mine sorry
i apologize is there any way to get the
screen back
i wouldn't know without seeing what your
um
screen's showing um at the moment
unfortunately
it's hard to know when i don't know what
the uh issue is it's just showing me the
screen saver
alex it just means that your connection
is quite low at the moment and
it will come back as soon as you think
your connection improves
thank you in that case then can we go
on to item nine which is the end
agency spend for quarter two i believe
you're dealing with that sarah
what we're going to do in council events
is i'll i'll
um introduce the papers and then
colleagues may come in
and anna so in in respect of this
particular paper katie's going to come
in and give some detail but
i'd just like to take a couple of
minutes of the committee's time
and before i hand over to kate to to
just acknowledge that we have seen an
increase
in our agency spend in the last um in
the last period however
we do believe that this is directly
linked to the effects of covid
so that's in be that on our existing
workforce who may
and have been absent from work therefore
requiring agency backfill but also as
well
in taking into account the static nature
of the labor
because as you can imagine there's very
few people that are
minded to leave one job and start you
know they're given the uncertainty
that exists as a result of coding so
um i'm going to let pete present the
data but i just want to give an
assurance that we will continue to
closely monitor
our agency usage and we will seek to
minimise this
plan but obviously we have to make sure
that we
exercise our statutory responsibilities
so kate can i
hand over to you thank you thanks sarah
yep so i'm presenting the report on
agency spent for quarter two twenty
twenty twenty twenty one
so across the council the total agency
spend was one million
fifty nine thousand and eighty um eight
hundred thirty four pounds
um and it is a significant increase as
compared with the previous quarter of
around 170 k
um as sarah's details you know given the
context of the presses from the pandemic
actually quarter one had stayed very
stable
so as the pandemic came in actually it
was potentially a bit surprising last
quarter when the level didn't increase
massively
so i think there's been a bit of a delay
in terms of the pressures coming through
um and you know animate some of it will
be the invoices coming through as well
um so you know so that's that's more
positive in terms of it hasn't been two
quarters where it's increased
um in terms of looking at the across the
directorates there has been little or no
spending three out of the six
directorates which again is i'd say
fairly promising given the significant
pressures across the council
and which means you know those services
those directorates are you know managing
their resourcing positions well
um in the other directorates that have
been affected adult services has seen a
slight increase
um and the governance and community
strategy for
it community resource a slight increase
as well and but as is the case you know
month on month um the majority of the
spend continues to be in children's
services you know
and we talk about this every quarter
when we present this report
there are significant pressures in that
area um i think about three quarters of
our total council spend is within that
directorate
and actually about 92 of
um the spend within children's is in is
in the social worker arena um
so you know say you know previously
acknowledged pressures
um and the the directorate still can is
looking at different
um different ways to mitigate that
position
to move to a better more stable
resourcing position say the work the
work continues
and that was that was everything for me
on that report
so any questions
does anybody have any questions on the
agent's suspend paper
can i just ask how recruitment is going
because obviously that
impacts on the agency spend and if 92
of it has been on social workers i'm
just wondering where we're at with that
i know recruitment
lots of places are slowed down during
the pandemic
so i'll pick that up if that helps so i
think
in terms of our overarching recruitment
agenda
we still have a lot of activity in that
space so particularly in our children's
area
we have had um
some turnovers on state over
and we are in the process of filling
some of those positions
when i say turnover it's not true in the
sense of people not necessarily leaving
what opportunities presenting themselves
and people moving into different roles
within
the organisation so we do
have a number of vacancies within our
children's social care
area and we also are
looking to fill some temporary
opportunities
across the authority as well to support
the new track and traits
community response and now with the mass
testing the mass vaccination programme
so our recruitment agenda remains quite
high
and we have set up a resource which is
covered in the overarching hr report
and to try and support us to deliver our
resourcing needs
is that your question um yeah i'm so i'm
still concerned about what the actual
rate
of um of vacancies are because i saw
that there was an upturn
and i know there is always that
difference of people moving and taking
over opportunities but it doesn't really
explain what the movement
out of the local authority is into other
places or what the
actual vacancy rate is you would have
the detail in front of me but what i can
tell because our staff team
who is quite low and comparison with
amr our neighboring authorities and is
actually quite low in any event
but what we can do for the next meeting
report which shows
um our staff turn over and also as well
and what we have in in pipeline from a
recruiting perspective with that helmet
yeah it's only i'm concerned about
future planning because especially if
managers are going to be going from
managing eight people to managing six
people to managing eight
and what that impact might be okay thank
you
any further questions on this item yeah
please
chair if i may yes go ahead
yeah i i it's just someone would
possibly
enlighten me not immediately just it's
actually just on
on the proportion of spend on
the broad headings which actually is
agency compared with
established staff reporters and
and how that compares currently would
say the similar period last year i'm not
asking for any answers now but just
literally
you know at the moment what proportion
of is being spent agency
um how much is on time established staff
and
give me a better feeling for um i
suppose the size and significance
of the
oh sorry k i was going to just come in
and suggest that we
um we haven't probably got that
information to hand right now but we can
take it offline
and we can um produce the information
and bring it back to this committee
yeah yeah that's absolutely fine i did
say i wasn't for one minute expect
to be able to produce it like a rabbit
out of a heart or something you know
you would have been very impressed
though
[Laughter]
any further questions
i'm not surprised at all because of the
pandemic that has
spent has gone up and from what i read
in journals it's the same throughout the
country throughout
all councils
i think sarah i know it's not something
for you but i think we really need to be
looking at
how many people are actually going into
this profession
at university level because i think this
is a problem that's just going to
escalate
year on year it seems to be a career
that people no longer want to be
involved with
and we have to have a strategy going
forward
for when we just literally physically
can't attract any social workers
because nobody's doing the courses i
think it's a really good point council
of anything is something that i know
colleagues and across the gcs um
group are talking about and also in the
das group as well
and working with local universities and
working with local colleges
and we ourselves are looking at how we
grow our own social workers
yeah and help them from health and
social care practitioners and then grow
through
a career grade and but you're absolutely
right it's a challenge
it's a national challenge yeah
absolutely
um if there are no further questions on
on this item can we move on to the
workforce update for quarter two please
yeah thank you very much councillor
bennett and i guess following on from
our previous meeting
if councillors are happy i will take
that report
and take questions um however if it's
okay
i would just like to take this
opportunity to commend our workforce for
their ongoing commitment to providing
the best possible services
to the residential community the
trafford and it would be absolutely
remiss of me
not to thank the hr and health and
safety
for their absolute dedication this last
nine months
to ensuring the health safety and
well-being of the employees the traffic
has remained our number one priority and
i am happy to take any questions about
the content
contained within the workforce quarter
to update
thank you sarah does anybody have any
questions
on this report
please may i speak
certainly it's about the um
traffic traffic leisure trust employees
i believe none of them were furloughed
were they they were all
redeployed to different areas is that
still the case
oh is it is that not the case the
traffic leisure
start our employees council
automatically
delicious staff sorry i mean the leisure
staff
in terms of in terms of the the leisure
trust
and we've been waiting for the
legendaries to support them on their
people agenda
during and during the crisis and in
terms of anybody who is assigned to
leisure from the council we didn't
follow anyone
we didn't have any members of staff who
were fairly
part of our response to the crisis
thank you
oh i'm back thank you for that sarah
and can we now move on to the annual
leave policy update
and the annual leave banking scheme
please sarah
you can and i'm going to bring kate in
for this because she is the author of
this of this report and i've managed
this on our behalf so kate would you
like to come in and give an update to
committee please
thank you certainly thanks sarah yep so
this is a change the annual leave policy
specifically around a new scheme which
is leave banking scheme
um so this change has come about this
year partly to do with the pandemic
um you know obviously we've experienced
pressures which have meant that staff in
some
services may have found it more
difficult to take um
you know their full entitlement of leave
this year
um however you know generally this
scheme will give staff additional
flexibility
um on top of their normal leave and also
we've got as we angela mentioned earlier
we've got the
leave purchase scheme as well so it's
just another way of giving more options
for staff around managing their time
away from work um
so what currently happens is staff
obviously have quite generous
um leave um and currently they can
request to carry leave forward from one
levier to the next lead year
um but we'd also expect them if they do
carry leave across to have
plans to use their leave fairly soon um
so that they're not in a position where
they've got
um the full um current leave
leave for the year but also loads of
extra um
so that's what we normally expect
however we've brought in a new leaf
banking scheme
to give staff more flexibility and it
basically means that each year staff can
choose to move up to five days
um and pro rata for part-time employees
into a separate leave scheme so it will
sit alongside they'll have a normal leaf
scheme and then
they'll have a separate leave scheme so
they can move five days in each year
um up to a maximum at any one point in
time of 20 days so that will sit there
and they can use it as they want to um
so the the idea is it could be used for
a longer break from work so that could
be because they want an extended holiday
once we can go on holiday again
they might want to go on a long haul and
take three weeks away
um it may be that they've got some
family commitments they may be
supporting a relative so there'll be
lots of reasons that we'll support
colleagues to have that time away
um so that well that's the general rules
of the scheme there are
some exceptions um um so
where staff can take put more than five
days
into the scheme so quite often we'll
have scenarios at the moment where a
staff
member may have been off um sick for a
long period during a year
and they will have lots of leave to to
take and obviously they've got a right
to that leave
and so in cases like that or say
somebody's been on maternity leave they
could
move that move more than five days into
their scheme and say there'd be some
exceptions but there'd be
um director sign off for those to make
sure we're managing them appropriately
um and again another scenario will be
this year potentially there might be
some staff who need to carry a little
bit would like to carry
some into that new scheme because of the
pressures of pandemic
but that said we have been very clear
with managers that we
during this difficult year that we've
been you know managers have had to
ensure that staff take
good breaks from work and take regular
breaks away um because we're obviously
conscious that we need to do that to
ensure that they get that time
support their mental health and just to
you know to not
get away from works everybody needs that
time um
so the scheme is available to staff now
we've gone out with communications
staff so they can actively um start to
do that from now
um and we've basically got a system
we've got the self-service system
in our my trend system whereby staff um
they can see their current leave scheme
for their normal leave and they will see
a new scheme where they can
bank leave and move into that new scheme
okay and that's it on that one any
questions
does anyone have any questions for kate
on this item
okay can i just ask
obviously if deaf are able to
bank 20 days and
a lot of people do that it could be
a logistical nightmare to
enable people to have the time where
when they want it
so i don't know how you're going to
manage that if uh
if there is big take-up and i think you
know
there has to be something that um
you know draws that back to enable the
you know the smooth running of the whole
of the organization
okay yep council action so take that
point on board i mean the position at
the moment is
obviously um as is the case with the
existing leave scheme managers have to
authorize leave and we encourage staff
to have conversations with the managers
as early as possible
particularly if they want an extended
period of leave so
quite often the case at the moment would
be if somebody is thinking about
a long-haul holiday often they're
planning towards that so
you know again we'd want that to
continue with this new scheme
um but we'd also expect that you know
like most things there'll be variations
we wouldn't anticipate that a high
number of staff will want an extended
period
at the same time but say it's down to
services to
have those regular conversations in
their check-ins with their staff
to be able to balance their needs to
ensure that we're fair to everybody
but also at the same time that it isn't
putting an unnecessary impact on you
know the service
in terms of release okay can i just have
a follow-up
uh yes certainly sure yeah i mean i
think um there has to be some
kind of uh central control
over over that and then to make sure
that
the organization does you know
work work through it
in a way that will not affect
you know the as i say the good running
of the council really
and so i think i think that there has to
be some monitoring of the managers as
well
and how they're actually um you know
administering this
[Music]
these things sound good but in
when they work out in practice it
doesn't always work in the way that you
you may want it to work i'm not opposed
to it at all and
i i like the flexibility but you've got
to have one eye on the whole of the
organization
okay yeah i've agreed i mean what i
suppose we've been trying to do is
move to a position where we're
empowering managers to take control and
to manage their staff
and to look at sort of agreed release
but what we can do as well obviously
from the systems
is we can pull off reports and we can
monitor so we could start to see
the volume of um leave being accrued in
the schemes for different staff and then
we'd have a picture across different
services
if we can see there any trends across
the organization and we can certainly
feed that back to corporate directors
and services to help them to manage that
and have that overview
definitely i think that would be helpful
yeah
can we take that away and take a look at
it yeah
thank you i suspect there will be some
issues around school summer holidays
any further questions for case horse
area on this item
yes uh council accordingly um
similar to dave's uh question but it's
the other side of it
how does this affect severance this uh
banking of leave
uh either voluntary redundancy or
something like that
because actually you're going to have to
come up with
a scheme that sort of converts that into
money
um and that could be quite a lot if
we're doing
something major if a lot of people have
got 20 days stored up
that'll soon put pressure on us there's
another way of doing it through count
support council accordingly so if we do
identify a colleague who um
has applied to volunteer seven and don't
have leads to
facilitate them taking that leave before
their end date so therefore there's not
that conflict of
payment for outstanding holidays and the
exit cap
so so you know i think what was saying
and it's absolutely right
we have to deal with all of these cases
on an individual basis because
um everybody will have their own story
with them
and we would approach anybody exiting
the organization on my face if people
look at them
and their individual package and try and
work with them
to make sure that it worked out right
for them okay
thank you thank you any further
questions on this item
thank you now we'll move on to the
quarterly report on exemptions to the
sickness policy
thank you council event so i am i will
advise
the committee that there have been full
um applications received
and in this reporting period and four
applications approved
so two of those applications came from
our children's directorate
one from our adults directors and one
from our government community
um team and um
i i i have to say i'm pleased to say
that they have been approved with no
issues to
report at this stage
thank you as that as we're at the end of
the agenda now
can i thank you all for your attendance
and for all the hard work that's gone
into these reports
and have a nice evening